Oh
Hey
zone
turn
we just be down near baby I'm looking
now for you baby
you know what side come see me a figure
I know we barely know each other
[Music]
[Music]
so a little bit more timestamp this tee
ruk I look a little bit more in between
time than normal because on the at the
end of the workout I don't know if we
caught that but something hit me
I clearly ate something last night so
I've been been throwing up all morning
and now back to work
[Music]
[Music]
I threw up all over myself I mean I
didn't and I'm just throw up in the
toilet button
it's clearly 8 something last night so
it's gonna be a long day that kind of
energy
sure actually met you at so soil you
know
yes book sign you're across Italy yes
one and I do want to on YouTube and I
saw you on the Larry King show a lot and
you're amazing getting chills but thank
you Frank yeah thank you what's your
name - Paul Paul real pleasure thanks
for saying hello yeah man I wish you
well
how are you gonna feel
hey guys how are you yes good to see ya
good oh well
we Nvidia pursue me that you something
but Astaire yeah
so back hey James yeah we're on that's
going it's good to be back oh yeah feels
so weird that's our real thing you know
we're a little early like in our
combination of it like like just
thinking about how I mean I think it's
the biggest pillar we play on I think
it's the biggest thing we're doing
you're doing a great job I'm super
pumped
honestly I'm what I'm more worried about
actually it's why paint you on that's
looking positively likely and you I'm
just scared that's not even a good deal
for me got it and so that's what's not
allowing me to do this like I I'm being
dead serious with you I'm gonna sell
400,000 copies in the first week of my
next book I think things have to have a
real meat on the bones I think look I
think for sure
and I think but I mean here's a big
thing I think this thing breaks if it's
on me to tell you what to do Andy okay
how did you have lunch with Arjun hey
Facebook it's me Gary Vaynerchuk former
host of Wine Library TV if you're seeing
this video I'm running Facebook ads
against fans of me and Wine Library and
other wine interests weird question yeah
that actually just spurred my mind it's
a good question it's a good question
you think I'm a better guy now by being
here ya know like have you been proud of
like like the way you said it was such a
warm thing like with that just like like
I think you're getting that you know you
never like we haven't been close in a
business setting in a long time
like I know even even like for example
my mother who do I love more than my mom
my wife luckily there's a lot of people
that don't know how great of a guy I
really am because they don't have the
data so and I don't talk about I drink
the kool-aid longer of course you know
who I am but like like when I'm on the
phone with these people recruiting I
like say you know I've been working for
over 15 years service
yep it's like yeah it's really great
when there's black and white examples
now no matter what industry you're
freaking in another son here you'd make
the other decision 100% and that ripples
through these people no question yeah
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 2 24 of the ask gary be
show it's gonna be what its release
I don't know if you guys were called but
I had a massive request to have what yes
you guys can do anything you want what
you can't do is not do something hey how
are you good I loved all I loved all
your Instagram photos she's rocking it
yes this is [ __ ] awesome all right
who knows who knows who that is
not one of you know who that is
po guys it's mr. Sandman he's the
hardest boxer in this game he's tougher
than Tyson Tyson has a pattern Sandman's
got one tweak to a pattern it's the only
like weird alternative and he's the only
guy that gave me trouble this is not in
the right order because super macho man
was before Sandman who put this together
all right
that's something that a human that gets
this forwarded to that doesn't give a
[ __ ] about us and his best friends with
the creative director from if they're
gonna just be careful that a senior
person gave them a deck and they just at
least want to know what's on there
because they have no [ __ ] interest in
working with us that's the kind of thing
that may get them say huh I just want to
put like actual Vayner work January 1st
or just like do you see what I mean like
you've got like I'm thinking the reason
I'm good at selling is its seconds the
reason everybody thinks I'm a jerk is I
talk over everybody is cuz you're losing
in the room it's already over
unfortunately it's so sad it's why
politicians do what they do this stuff
always plays the best like if you it's
really so sad that we live in a society
we're like hey you suck [ __ ] is usually
the best way to get somebody to do
something sucks but
yeah but we don't want to me I'm like
them desperately don't want to be
alright hurry come on it you want to
call you - good come on excellent I
don't want to lose any time just need to
see one thing from him I saw I saw
headline one well great okay how you
doing good hey good day
what do you think this has been all
about but even I but it's really just
it's just one replication of Who I am as
a human I lost in school
I'm the people's people people don't get
it
I've been trying to tell everybody I'm
bad at normal look I don't know how to
win that game
Bret do you think like like genuinely I
can't win in normal stuff maybe I'll do
a little talking here jumping into three
uh three drinks here at lore great
little restaurant in New York City
so hope i thinkI rock rocks gonna go in
gently so we'll catch up with you in a
little bit good day though like it's
unbelievable how intoxicating getting
back on the action is for me and I miss
Judy rock rock this is for you show me
still hustling on Twitter and snapchat
right now
with some stuff I just need to finish
inna
if it still in the me